having a problem with pests in your home
can be a huge inconvenience however the
council offers a pest control service
where you can get advice and help on
getting rid of a range of pest problems
in your home whether it's rats mice
foxes or fleas we have a series of
advice leaflets available in reception
areas both in rochford and rayleigh and
on the website at www k /s to control
the leaflets contain lots of useful
advice to household is about a range of
different pests and how to control them
there are certain circumstances where
professional treatment is required in
these cases the council has negotiated
preferred rates to get rid of pests such
as rats mice the bedbugs and wasps and
the pricing guide for pest control
services are wasps and bees 41 pounds 70
fleas another insects 83 pound 40
bedbugs 166 pound 80 and rats and mice
38 pound and the price for the last item
includes v80 in cases where a resident
is in receipt of a means-tested benefit
the council will reduce the charge for
insect infestations that are of concern
to public health such as fleas and
bedbugs the most important thing to do
if you notice you have pests in your
home is to get help to find out about
how to use this service or get advice
phone our customer services team on 0 1
702 3181 double one
working together free NHS health checks
if you are between 40 and 74 years old
you can get a free NHS health check to
help you prevent heart disease diabetes
stroke and kidney disease your inner
chest health check will include blood
pressure pulse cholesterol BMI body mass
index and a personalized lifestyle plan
NHS health checks assess people's risk
of developing heart disease type 2
diabetes kidney disease and stroke the
health check is available to people
between 40 and 74 who are not already
under the care of their GP for these
conditions or on treatment for high
blood pressure or cholesterol Associate
Director of Public Health at NHS south
east essex Margaret grey said everyone
is at risk of developing heart disease
stroke diabetes or kidney disease the
good news is that these conditions can
often be prevented even if you have a
history of them in your family have your
free NHS health check and you will be
better prepared for the future and be
able to take steps to maintain or
improve your health NHS health checks
are being offered nationally to help
prevent the onset of these health
problems everyone between the ages of 40
and 74 who has not been diagnosed with
the conditions mentioned will be invited
for a check once every five years by
their GP if you are outside this age
range and concerned about your health
you should contact your GP prevention is
better than cure so contact your GP
today to book your free NHS health check
for information visit www.pay 40.com you
have to act fast if you suspect a stroke
fast is face has their face fallen on
one side can they smile arms can they
raise both arms and keep them there
speech is their speech slurred and time
is time to pull 999 if you see any of
these signs NHS southeast essex is
supporting the Department of Health's
memorable at
fast campaign to raise public awareness
about the signs and symptoms of stroke
and a need to act quickly if a stroke is
suspected every year around 110,000
people in England have a stroke it is
the third leading cause of death and
there are at least 300,000 people in
England living with disabilities as the
result of a stroke there are two main
types of stroke haemorrhagic stroke
caused when a weakened blood vessel in
the brain bursts this produces bleeding
into the brain which leads to damage
esteem extra' caused by a clot of
narrowing or blocking of blood vessels
so the blood cannot to reach a
particular area of the brain this leads
to death of the brain cells due to lack
of oxygen a mini stroke is called a
transient ischaemic attack or ti a it is
similar to a stroke that has the same
science but it gets better within 24
hours however it could be a warning sign
of a more serious stroke and it's vital
that it gets the same fast action the
act fast campaign uses a simple
checklist to help everyone recognized
the tell-tale signs of stroke and
advises of the action to take prompt
action after a stroke is vital as it can
prevent further damage to the brain a
delay can result in major long-term
disabilities that is why it is crucial
for as many people as possible to learn
how to act fast are you confident you
can spot the signs of stroke you can
take the interactive test online at WWDC
UK forward slash act fast suspect a
stroke act fast and call 999
being prepared for flooding could save
your life and your property floods can
happen anywhere at any time caused by
rising ground water overwhelmed drainage
systems hillside run off due to sudden
heavy rain as well as flooding from
rivers and the sea even if you live
miles from the coast or a river flooding
can affect you you can prepare for
flooding by following a few small steps
to reduce the impact on your home step
one find out if you live in an area at
risk from sea or river flooding and sign
up to the flood line direct a free
service that provides warnings direct to
you by telephone mobile SMS email or fax
to find out more about flood line direct
visit w WM virant hyphen agency UK or
call 0845 nine double eight double 188
step to make a flood plan and know how
to turn off gas water and electricity
supplies step three have a flood kit
include your torch wind up radio
important telephone numbers and bottled
water step 4 think about what can be
moved to a safe place now items such as
photograph old albums family videos and
treasured items step 5 think about what
you would want to move to safety if
flooding is forecast for example cars
furniture septics protect your property
from flooding while it is impossible to
completely flood-proof a property there
are lots of things you can do to reduce
flood damage by preventing or delaying
water entering your property a range of
guides can be found at ww environment
hyphen agency gov't UK or by calling
0845
double eight of one double eight to help
you prepare if you are in an animal or
pet then there are steps you can take to
make sure they are safe if there is
flooding here is some advice from animal
animal welfare charity the Blue Cross to
help you prepare be prepared because
some human shelters will not allow
animals bring the council's emergency
planning officer Peter McKenzie on 0170
23 1813 tuned to check make sure your
cats and dogs are wearing proper
identification the Blue Cross recommends
that all cats and dogs have both a
microchip and an identity tag on their
caller make sure food and medicines are
well stopped work out an escape route
and decide if you need extra gates for
emergency access the horses and other
animals in fields if there is a flood
warning bring all small animals inside
and if possible take them upstairs move
food bedding and fresh water to
somewhere safe and dry keep your
portable pet carriers at hand keep
familiar toys dry as animals under
stress will welcome something that
smells of home put documentation like
vaccination records your vets details a
microchip numbers in a sealed bag with
any other important documents move
horses to high ground and put your
contact details on field and all stable
gates so that you can be contacted in an
emergency and if disaster strikes cats
rabbits and other small animals must be
transported in suitable carriers birds
insecure cages and dogs using sturdy
leeches in cold weather put a blanket
over the carrier do not put water inside
the carrier during transportation
remember to take your animals food water
bowls and bedding with you
if you have no choice but to leave your
animals behind leave and shut in an
inside upstairs room with ample supplies
of food and water leave notices on
external door saying there are animals
inside and contact the rspca never put
your own or other human life in danger
to save an animal and for more
information visit the blue cross website
at www crows or guk
the humble garden shed is fast becoming
a target for thieves with security on
many houses upgraded burglars are opting
for easy pickings at the end of the
garden a shed or outbuilding is often
easier to break into and less likely to
be alarmed yet many carry expensive
gardening tools and equipment which are
easier to make off with than a computer
or television though cheaper to buy than
some household items they carry a
healthy secondhand value and are easy to
sell on the intruder may not even be
intent on stealing from said but simply
after a tool or implement to use to
break into the house itself as was the
case in a recent attempted burglary at a
residence in rochford the advice from
crime prevention experts is simple keep
your tools under lock and key but
remember cunning thieves won't let a
padlock fit it on a flimsy clasp get in
their way padlocks cheap and expensive
offer little protection and thieves have
been known to force open shed and roof
panels to get inside invest in a good
quality well-designed shed and think
about where you position it can it be
seen from the house consider installing
lights to illuminate that part of the
garden and fit a mains or
battery-powered alarm also make sure the
shed is firmly anchored to the ground it
has been known for sheds to be lifted to
let thieves inside doors and windows
should be first firmly secured coach
bolts are preferable to screws when
securing hinges and fitting window film
to any glass will increase its strength
should these exterior defenses be
breached protect your possessions by
fitting a wire cage inside the shed
where more expensive items can be locked
away store power tools in a lockable Box
secured to the floor or a wall anchor a
thick cable to the floor and attach it
to larger items then secure with a good
quality paddle no thief wants to hang
about long
than they have to so delay the time it
will take them to break into your shed
the harder you make it for them the
greater the chance they'll give it up as
a bad job and don't forget that includes
bicycles to bicycles are best locked
away in a properly secured shed or
garage when not in use don't take a
chance by leading your bike unsecured in
the garden or propped up alongside the
house overnight police in the
southeastern district dealt with 45
reported bike thefts between april and
September last year almost a third of
these involved bikes being taken from
gardens these crimes are easily
prevented by straw in the bike away in a
shed or garage if this isn't possible
cyclists should invest in a good quality
lock and secure their bikes to an
immovable object tucked away from public
view if possible cyclists are further
urged to take care of their bikes when
out and about and certainly never leave
them propped up outside a shop when
going inside it takes seconds for
someone to ride off with it so it really
is worth taking the extra time to lock
the bike to an object such as a lamppost
or bike rack
you